I'm honored to be able to stand before
all of you extremely humbled to be able
to stand here today recently I wrote to
chief difava and several members of the
MIT police department I wanted them to
know that I had been keeping all police
officers in my thoughts and prayers I
told them as I will tell you that I know
that this is a difficult time for all of
us and judging by our numbers here today
and by the intensive conversations that
we have shared I also know that it has
been extremely hard for us to
continuously witness even from a
distance the tragic deaths of innocent
men and women often black men and women
as well as the tragic deaths of police
officers committed to their profession
officers who were fulfilling their duty
to protect and serve on this latter
point I would like to make a declarative
statement but in doing so I acknowledge
that I am taking a Liberty a Liberty
that will enable me to attempt to speak
for most black people and speaking for
most not to mention all black people is
not something that I take lightly but
today I take this Liberty because I
truly believe that I stand with most
when I say that as black people
specifically we believe that what
happened in Dallas was wrong it was
heartbreaking it was a grave injustice
in the face of so many others and most
of us would not only agree with dr.
King's or
we would espouse them as our personal
beliefs returning violence for violence
multiplies violence adding deeper
darkness to a night already devoid of
stars darkness cannot drive out darkness
he says only light can do that hate
cannot drive out hate only love can do
that clearly feelings of helplessness
hurt anger and rage have been expressed
here today feelings that many of us in
this room have been concealing and
holding in for far too long these
feelings are genuine and in many ways
unavoidable and certainly undeniable we
need and deserve time to grieve life
however has taught me that if we stay in
a state of helplessness too long it can
and will cloud our vision our
perspective and our reality because in
reality we as individuals and certainly
we as the MIT community are not helpless
for MIT is renowned in name many in
numbers powerful in presence and
virtually unparalleled in our capacity
to solve the world's greatest challenges
in fact when it comes to solving the
world's greatest problems the world
often looks to us in the space called
problem solving MIT sits in a unique and
often unrivaled position so my MIT
family I do not believe that we are
helpless because only a university with
a president who is confident in its
ability to positively impact an
influence social political and economic
change would challenge itself its
students its faculty its staff and its
alumni to make
a better world as a nation I do not
believe that we are incapable of rising
above our current state we can seek
peace we can implement legislation
policies practices and a level of
democratic and community policing that
will not only heal our land but increase
trust and create an environment that
ensures safety and security for all so
today I urge us not to give in to the
darkness the darkness of doubt and fear
instead let us embrace the light that
shines so brightly within each of our
hearts and our minds for it has been
said that our deepest fear is not that
we are inadequate our deepest fear is
that we are powerful beyond measure it
is our light not our darkness that most
frightens us and that light my friends
that life-giving life changing
infinitely powerful and brilliantly few
light is not just in some of us it is in
each and every one of us so we must
boldly and responsibly shine our lights
we must carry our torches our lanterns
our beacons our lightsabers we must
carry them as symbols of hope and use
them for good for they will be a lamp
into our feet illuminating the pathway
that will enable us to truly see one
another to respect one another to love
one another and to stand together as one
to stand together against injustice
intolerance and hatred our lights must
shine so bright that others will not
only see our great dome in killing in
court but they will see our good works
and they will be inspired to pick up
their torches as well and finally we
must use the power of the light
that is harness within us to eradicate
the darkness that attempts to cloak
individuals and systems that perpetuate
racism oppression and violence against
any group mit we have been called for
such a time as this we are the chosen
for we are called to make a better world
I will do my part will do you do yours
will you do your part to make a better
world thank you for being here today
yes sir
you